[Music]
during the warmer months especially at
night during the full moon horseshoe
crabs emerge from the sea to spawn
waiting for them our teams of lab
workers who capture the horseshoe crabs
by the hundreds of thousands
take them to labs harvest their cerulean
blood then return them to the sea
oddly enough we capture horseshoe crabs
on the beach because that's the only
place we know we can find them a female
horseshoe crab lays as many as 20
batches of up to 4,000 eggs on her
annual visit to the beach when the eggs
hatch the juvenile horseshoe crabs often
stay near shore periodically shedding
their shells as they grow once they
leave these shallow waters they don't
return until they reach sexual maturity
10 years later despite our best efforts
we don't know where they spend those
years though we've spotted the
occasional horseshoe crab as deep as 200
metres below the ocean's surface we only
see large groups of adults when they
come ashore to spawn
horseshoe crab blood contains cells
called amoeba sites that protect them
from infection by viruses fungi and
bacteria amoeba sites formed gels around
these invaders to prevent them from
spreading infections this isn't unusual
all animals have protective immune
systems but horseshoe crab amoeba sites
are exceptionally sensitive to bacterial
endotoxins endotoxins are molecules from
the cell walls of certain bacteria
including ecoli large amounts of them
are released when bacterial cells die
and they can make us sick if they enter
the bloodstream many of the medicines
and medical devices we rely on can
become contaminated so we have to test
them before they touch our blood we do
have tests called gram stain's that
detect bacteria but they can't recognize
endotoxins which can be there even when
bacteria aren't present
so scientists use an extract called
Lal produced from harvested horseshoe
crab blood to test for endotoxins they
add Lal to a medicine sample and if gels
form bacterial endotoxins
are present today the Lal test is used
so widely that millions of people who've
never seen a horseshoe crab have been
protected by their blood if you've ever
had an injection that probably includes
you
how did horseshoe crabs end up with such
special blood like other invertebrates
the horseshoe crab has an open
circulatory system this means their
blood isn't contained in blood vessels
like ours instead horseshoe crab blood
flows freely through the body cavity and
comes in direct contact with tissues if
bacteria enters their blood it can
quickly spread over a large area pair
this vulnerability with the horseshoe
crabs bacteria filled ocean and
shoreline habitats and it's easy to see
why they need such a sensitive immune
response horseshoe crabs survived mass
extinction events that wiped out over
90% of life on earth and killed off the
dinosaurs but they're not invincible
and the biggest disruptions they've
faced in millions of years come from us
studies have shown that up to 15% of
horseshoe crabs die in the process of
having their blood harvested and recent
research suggests this number may be
even higher researchers have also
observed fewer females returning to
spawn at some of the most harvested
areas our impact on horseshoe crabs
extends beyond the biomedical industry
to coastal development destroys spawning
sites and horseshoe crabs are also
killed for fishing bait there's ample
evidence that their populations are
shrinking some researchers have started
working to synthesize horseshoe crab
blood in the lab for now we're unlikely
to stop our beach trips but hopefully a
synthetic alternative will someday
eliminate our reliance on the blood of
these ancient creatures ted-ed
is a non-profit and this video would not
exist without the support of our
incredible community on patreon you can
learn more here
[Music]